leave me alone at this point i'm minding
my business i don't do anything i don't
say anything
leave me alone
haley bieber has had enough enough time
has gone by where it's valid to leave me
alone i beg of you truly
that's my only request
leave me alone
be miserable somewhere else please
the video comes shortly after the model
responded to a rumor surrounding her
marriage with justin bieber which all
started last month a tick-tocker who
makes predictions about celebrity
relationships said this about the couple
specifically i feel like this month we
may actually find out there's trouble in
paradise with justin bieber and his wife
haley biebs i feel like things may be on
the rocks haley's response l-m-f-a-o
that's about it
but it seems like the former drop the my
coast is the topic of rumors lately just
last week justin and haley stepped out
at the grammy awards both looking
stunning as ever even sharing some pda
on the carpet
[Applause]
but it's her attire that caught people's
eye as haley wore a loose cream saint
laurent strapless gown it prompted fans
to question if the model was hiding a
baby bump but she quickly shut it down
commenting on an instagram post about
the fan's speculation writing i'm not
pregnant leave me alone and it seems the
build up of haley's frustrations has
eventually led to this
leave me alone at this point i'm minding
my business i don't do anything i don't
say anything
leave me alone please enough time has
gone by where it's valid to leave me
alone i beg of you truly
that's my only request
leave me alone be miserable somewhere
else please
well someone who's sure to have her back
during these hard times her hubby justin
who even proved it during her most
recent health scare
[Music]
last month haley revealed on instagram
she was hospitalized for a blood clot
the 25 year old describes the experience
as definitely one of the scariest
moments she's ever been through most of
you probably know or seen
the news about my wife i'm not sure if
you guys seen
but she's okay
she's good
she's strong
uh but it's been scary you know like
it's been really scary
but a source told et at the time the
entire health scare elevated the
couple's marriage it's an amazing
feeling the source says haley went
through a traumatic experience with her
blood clot but she's doing much better
and is healthy and despite it being
traumatic this solidified that justin
will always be by her side through thick
and thin and make sure she is taken care
of and supported in any capacity haley
is his world and he could never imagine
life without her this brought them
closer together than ever before and it
was a reminder for both of them to
really appreciate each other and their
special relationship
[Music]